[Music]
dear mum
i have to figure out who i really am i'm
sorry for leaving
but i knew that you would try to stop
hello darling
dear mom i'm sorry for leaving again
the world is a scary place but i can
look after myself mom
when it comes to girls you've always
been a duck out of water look
so completely fine then what don't worry
i want you to have some
fun you have to speak to the next woman
who walks in this one whoever they are
i thought it would be nice to come for a
drink here with dad oh is he coming down
you're leaning on him oh god i'm so i'm
so sorry
fun thought let's say it is the end of
the world and we will have two weeks to
live what would you do eat donuts and
try and have sex with people all right
go on kid what about you
[Music]
hello jimmy you killed my dad
remember me kim's been a long time
what's the what's that gonna happen
there's two dead people we need to leave
bro what's happening who are they why
are they attacking you
okay we're trucked in a house with some
weirdo who thinks it's the end of the
world
she's not a weirdo you don't even know
her i know well enough
if he gets half a chance he'll kill
every single one of us
would anyone like our chocolate finger
wow
[Applause]
this is the world that you're so
desperate to explore
you lied to me mum my whole life is
alive
your needs are help love makes you do
stupid [ __ ]
nikki
excuse me
[Music]
you